oui nous avons besoin d'un plan si vous voulez reconstruire
vous devez avoir un plan oui nous pouvons
bien sûr aider
nos villes Paris peut-être dans la
transformation de l'infrastructure pour
passer d'une voiture à un vélo est très
intéressant car parce que c'est un nouveau
modèle pas nouveau  modèle parce que Copenhague
et une autre ville en Europe sont
très engagées dans ces politiques et
où, pour moi, Copenhague était
un exemple pour Paris dans ce plan, mais nous
pouvons travailler ensemble avec nos expériences
avec nos
forces également où nous sommes des villes intelligentes, mais  il
faut organiser ça